this show is brought to you by texture
go to texture calm / Joey and they're
offering our listeners a free trial
you'll gain immediate entry to all the
top magazines including back issues in
bonus video content that texture calm /
Joey show is also brought to you by blue
apron calm go to blue apron calm / Joey
and check out this week's menu and get
your first three meals for free with
free shipping included that's blue apron
calm / Joey blue apron calm / Joey oh
[ __ ] Halloween is not creeping up on you
it's the Church of what's happening now
[ __ ] without the candle I forgot it
what are you gonna do strap on your
[ __ ] seatbelts I could have
been backstage at Black Sabbath but I
[ __ ] went with you [ __ ] you
know why because I love it
10 o'clock after I talk to a kid I
haven't spoken to in two [ __ ] years
cause and he goes my girlfriend can't
[ __ ] go today and you're the only
other friend Sabbath fanatic he got the
VIP package the whole [ __ ] why didn't
you couldn't you know you're gonna told
me I would've come it's not about that
it's about commitment we got to give
these people they wake up one day morals
Tuesday hey you go [ __ ]
kick that mule Lee
you
oh my god at that foot Church of what's
happened now with my main man Lisa at
and Josh out of mine
what's up everybody master of [ __ ]
music I love it to death we want to talk
about the goddamn Comedy Jam knowing
that foreign stuff we took I want it
first I want to give a shout out to the
man of the church Bobby Sheeran Don
Austin for almost killing Lee he took
the Chuy's and barbeque oh my ax
barbecue the best two weeks wasn't
experienced like I can't even I feel
like a lot of people who listen and
watch to this Joey
alright like they'll they laugh but
they're like why is Joey so so like
buddies have all these rules about food
ranches okay I like hummus but after
going to specifically Chuy's I can
understand a little bit of why you get
so serious like what about food what do
you what do you what rules do you have I
just don't understand why eating this
[ __ ] when the good shits available to
you with like fast food and things like
that or just a bunch of [ __ ] like that
yeah
we [ __ ] complain it's on TV but it's
like anything else in life you know they
advertise cigarettes or cure you I smoke
cigarettes with ten [ __ ] knees no
pain okay we all did mm-hmm it's no
difference but when it comes to food I
have this [ __ ] burning desire like
after my mother died I didn't eat that
food no more just cuz I knew would never
be the same
mm-hmm nobody's gonna make it like moms
and I've tried it one time I broke my
rule I almost want to shoot myself
what do you mean that comfort food or
like me I'm packing food like a Cuban
food Chinese food [ __ ] you know [ __ ]
like that
do you eat Chinese food I mean I do but
I haven't found a place out here
okay so I'm with one that that's what
I'm talking about [ __ ] like that mm-hmm
that will keep going with shitty Chinese
restaurant then one day you're like why
am i eating this this is not what I grew
up with yes a hundred this is not wine
I'm never eating again like the whole
when I was in San Francisco doing
outside lands like we went to Chinatown
and there's a spot there that I long net
and I [ __ ] ate there and it was it
was incredible it was incredible spot
but out here I don't have one you know
no and you'll have one for awhile and
then they'll go sour on you I had that
experience now last night not with
Chinese food
like what am I like [ __ ] up meals is
Shake Shack which is just like that in
New York like burger it's like a burger
place it's like it's like a in and out
for like the East Coast but they opened
up one on like in like boy town like one
like Crescent neck resonates with La
Cienega in Santa Monica and and I went
there last night I've been going there
not routinely but like once every couple
weeks and I went there last night and it
wasn't right
it's didn't taste right and now I'm done
with it because it's about consistency
again it's all consistency nobody wants
to be consistent though just be
consistent and that corporate says I
don't have to cook you know I'm saying
like when we were kids we grew up at
Mitch's deli okay I'm just saying in
there but but I've been in Mitch's menu
at my mansion
they're all what have you had your Mitch
Mike the least I gotta to hot brother
these mics at Dubai want to blow each
other out here well everybody has them
Mitch's deli mmm so now you're going to
that deli you become friends with Mitch
he knows what you want he even goose on
you oh it's mr. monster with turkey
young of a [ __ ] piece of rye bread
gravy artist rides all right you know
you put me out of business a lot of
gravy you get next thing you know I know
I should charge you but I don't
and they bust your balls yeah of course
then when something's [ __ ] up you
could say Mitch what the [ __ ] you didn't
put your glasses on tonight Mitchell I'm
sorry I'll throw in a complimentary
pickle you know you're coming in Chinese
I'm gonna bite your pickle you slippin
yeah it's done he'll only do that once
in his life because maybe his ball is
staying out late and my mistake you put
[ __ ] mustard instead of mayonnaise
sure sure
you know I'm saying I go to that I used
to go a couple weeks like a year ago
mm-hmm lose weight so sometimes I go by
that [ __ ] Jersey Mike's all I want is
turkey on wheat with cheese mayonnaise
and [ __ ] lettuce in the tomato some
pepper do you know I asked them like
three times they [ __ ] that sandwich Oh
how do they [ __ ] that up we don't why
tell you why because the [ __ ] the
dude stop [ __ ] and he goes what do you
want you
and then he puts him the thing so this
jerk-off over here is putting [ __ ] on
the thing he's talking to you but also
he goes what do you want on yours so
nobody could he's get like five orders
at once no reasoning so you say somebody
says jalapenos are next mean you know
I'm wishing bro unless you grow up in
there you're not gonna be that good that
Jersey might [ __ ] so up to three or four
times they [ __ ] up my sandwich I can't
go back there not to mention it's
[ __ ] horrific yeah their kids working
anew its own academy he'll say it's
horrific nobody do most people that work
in places don't give a [ __ ] about that's
why my dad always said this and this
isn't my respect more than anything
you're gonna go to a restaurant make
sure the owners there make sure the
owners in the building no chains no [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] if they've got two
stores like he's like go to the one that
the owner you know what i'ma go to the
original joint because they give a [ __ ]
you know I mean when I grew up we never
went there just like Outback Steakhouse
it was like there was popular restaurant
in Germantown Maryland where I grew up
and we never went there we always went
to like Italian Pines or we wanted a
steak we went to like Chris fields or
some [ __ ] like that it was just that was
what my dad believed in and every time
we went there there was a dope meal food
was right and like you said if they
[ __ ] it up they were like oh you
didn't enjoy it tonight mr. Myers let me
hook you up you know I mean I throw I'll
give you some tiramisu or something
hearing me yeah you know it's just I'm
used to all those little things I'm used
to uh you know the food to be qua like
and and I catch myself a lot of times I
go to a place eat and go that wasn't bad
then I go there again there's I mean
like oh this is [ __ ] terrible mm-hmm
this is [ __ ] terrible mm-hmm so with
Lee if there's a bad restaurant
léo pickin he's just got that I love
with all my heart
he's a great kid everybody plays a be
good there's a first is the first
intention it's just god-awful
then you sit there and go wait I can't
believe this is what you look at sadly
were in the hotel well that calm I know
what's going on I think
I just woke up now we actually sat that
they before breaking down austin food
you know that specialty is Franklin's
its barbecue who acts and all that stuff
and we spoke about Chuy's and papacito's
and all these little mom-and-pop
thoughtful places he mentioned a few
trucks he's from Connecticut Bobby Zarin
so he said you know the Chinese really
just god-awful there's once but there's
always that one spot that's a five
mm-hmm but when they [ __ ] it up it's a
three so that you don't go back again
mm-hmm and he he said all this stuff you
know the Chinese food just got awful
that's why I talked to me and it's
likely never heard the conversation he
goes this is Chinese place up the corner
over here I heard the conversation son
pound or some [ __ ] boom bow whatever bow
bow
I don't know what I'm [ __ ] Asians
that we grew up and never made it down
here yeah it's just I've never come to
Austin if somebody said you gotta go to
this Chinese restaurant never 20 years
ago Lee you're in the land the [ __ ]
you know and you want to go to some dumb
but we just discussed this yeah well he
was gone it was right I got a sick a
billy goat meat and the whole thing
he's picking like lobster rolls in Idaho
yeah it's just you know it's a shine
yeah it was right across the street he
believes y'all and he listens to Yelp
Yelp said crackers so yeah there's all
these [ __ ] Gentiles that live around
the corner live in Studio City yeah they
know about they don't know anything
not that they [ __ ] pizza from that
place with it if you eat the salad you
will know your wife will give birth
every day get the [ __ ] out of here
some [ __ ] salad dressings gonna make
my wife snap [ __ ] people the queso at
Chuy's was okay I've never had anything
like it I've never had case of queso dip
yeah okay so I dude I date dude I date
this girl and she's from like South
Carolina man and she's we go to the
supermarket like we should get some
queso dip I'm like that's that's [ __ ]
white trash it right now how about salsa
baby you know I love you that the case
old Joe Carolina is [ __ ] disgusting
because they probably make the
slices yeah yeah this whole clock is up
but listen to me this case I did was
legit your world would chew ease as a
Mexican as a tax Mexican recipe I need
sincerely I sincerely as I can I used to
go to Houston I've showed people YouTube
videos I shot cocaine after a two week
stint in Houston you look at me and go
Joey
what happened I know it's the number one
place for bad fat people Houston attack
so I know that number two is Dallas
why didn't tell is because the food is
garbage no they said that queso dip
kawatche is for breakfast did you walk
into a restaurant me he's gonna high I
love a Cal Shanklin with oatmeal
sprinkled with goat cheese
they will throw a beating on you you
know that they probably served that like
Barnaby's the one gay restaurant but
Barnaby's also relies on meatloaf I was
telling him that when you cut it has
boots or no cheese a little chunks of
garlic gonna in you never seen though
you're making me hungry without passion
mashed potatoes with gravy on the side
no listen between you and me really
great we do cuz his animals out there
there's animals out there you sure you
know to be when you travel you realize
that eight out of ten brown gravy so
[ __ ] horrific mm-hmm horrific this
place is gravy this is in Houston I'll
be in Houston in November well I'm will
you make oh yeah you go and you [ __ ] you
in the show dude yeah yeah I get red
band to do it Tony did he just did the
show and he made it was gated great he
did George Michaels
Careless Whisper in Tony's voice it
didn't change and get melodic it was
just I'm never gonna dance again
no that's a good you know what's a good
song for the goddamn County
what's that tan tan tan tan the dancer
then the dander dander dander there the
dander dander dander there Oh George
Michael but unknown
oh dude Justin Martindale didn't like
what so will it's called freedom freedom
yeah well here's what here's what's
funny I wasn't he but this is like we'd
already done like three or four shows at
that point and like he had left me
friends with him for a while and he's
like he's like Josh I want to do the
show and oh my god I'll get you man
don't worry and he's just kept bugging
me and bugging me goes dude I know what
song I want to do I go we'll just tell
me anyway I mean I don't really have
spots coming up and he said George
Michael freed him and I go you're doing
it next month it's like one of my
favorite that was the first show that
that that people stood up and danced
that was he was the first guy to go up
and nobody is because the first like for
shows like everybody just sat there and
they were enjoying it but they just
didn't get into it and halfway through
the song he stops and it was like I told
him I was like if you're gonna do the
show you could do this song I need you
to go a million percent gay dude I need
you to be full-fledged homosexual when
you're doing this song and dude halfway
through he stopped and he goes get up
you [ __ ] [ __ ] and everybody stood
up and from that point on the sooner the
music hits everybody stands now high
like the goddamn calmly Jam get creative
um so we used to do a theater show at
this play do you ever do the unknown
theater on Santa Monica and Seward Sarah
Tiana and this girl or Valdivia in this
room it was in this old theater like
kind of in the theater district but in a
cut like it was it was like hidden from
everybody it was more of a speakeasy
than theater like it was a theater the
guy put on plays but like every play
probably lost money cause like the dude
was like great at building sets and so
one month you perform in there and
you're performing in like I get onstage
would be like a gay bathhouse and then
like two months later you're performing
it like a gay resort it was always a gay
related good one one year we were like
before me inside a gay man's [ __ ] it
was just everything was gay related for
all of his plays but he was super
straight dude just put on gay plays so
we do the shows there and every night
the show would end and they'd a bunch of
musical instruments so we'd all pull
them up and we just start [ __ ] around
and be like me bread urns then Chris
Porter Sarah Tiana the bird started
showing up and everybody would drink
until like 2:00 3:00 4:00 in the morning
and it just kind of got started there
and then when the girls left this dude I
worked on this we took the show over and
me and this other dude with
let's bring a band into it to be like a
house band so there the light so when
you started you were like performing
they bring you up and then they walk
offstage you do your set and then we
didn't want to let you like the band
would come back on stage and then you'd
wrap up your set and sometimes comics
would start [ __ ] around with the band
but what songs do you know and then
somebody they start playing it and then
they sing it so that's how the idea got
kind of like started that theater then
shut down and I became cool with the
band that was her house band and I just
kept in touch with we started getting
booked at different spots and then we
moved to a place in Studio City we did
two shows it was cool but it really
didn't pick up you know I mean he's just
a weird venue called murica's the chick
that ran it was a [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
like she was completely insane didn't
really we packed the house out she was
just ripping us off so then we stopped
but at that show Adam Devine went up and
he did he did a song instead of doing
his set he was like what songs you know
and the band is like won't I forget what
song it was it was like sugar sugar or
some [ __ ] like that
and he played it and the audience went
bananas and at that point that's 2010
that's when I was like that's the show
right there that's the show now I was at
2010 I've been doing comedy two years
I'm a I'm a good enough comic you know
what I mean I can definitely I know how
to make people laugh I was doing well I
wasn't passing any real clubs yet but I
was like doing shows but I wasn't ready
to do that show the way I wanted to do
it so I sat on it and I got better at
stand-up and then you know they went
through some certain [ __ ] that kind of
changed everything in 2012 and then
started getting more and more
opportunities out here like I like I got
Montreal and like was on every showcase
and I was touring a little bit and I was
making money but I wasn't getting what I
wanted out of this town I was like you
know we were talking before you turn the
mics on like this town is it's a funky
ass town man you know what I mean like
you could be the most talented person in
the world but you ain't getting [ __ ] and
other people are just surpassing you and
it was really jfl that did it new faces
just [ __ ] with me because that was
supposed to be the turning point in my
career the house wasn't give me
everything it didn't and so I was gonna
move to New York and then right
for like a year year around that point
after I did new faces I was like you
know what before I moved to New York let
me try this show out and it was really
just gonna be you do a set and then you
do a song there was gonna be no story
and I was talking to this like much
bigger comic trying to pitch him the
idea and he was like a Dacia working as
a youth ain't gonna work and I'm like
why not he goes I there's a comic doing
a song and I'll see how that'll just be
weird and then I was with another comic
he goes he said maybe you should do
somethin tell a story you know I was
like yeah there it is dude that's the
[ __ ] bow and then we did the first
show and luckily I got bird to do the
first one he was super excited about it
and then it's just been a hit ever since
he put the wig on he did he that first
show I've never seen anybody get more
excited he played my drums he was always
he's the only guy that he doesn't sing
he sings in the final group song but he
used to play drums with us and that was
like I ran him do at the Comedy Store
like I had the idea somebody came up to
me says hey I want to do a show with you
and I'm like listen man I was like I
don't want to do a regular show I got
this idea and when I pitched the idea to
this dude he was like oh that's it man
100% we gotta [ __ ] do that and I'm
like yeah I'd say I don't know man isn't
gonna work or people gonna be into it's
hard to do a show out here in LA and
then a week later I ran into Burr and I
was like I was I started talking about
music and he goes you know - we should
start jamming again and I'm like well I
got this show idea and immediately he
was just like I'm in because I shoot my
special the end of June he goes set it
up for July and then I was like [ __ ] it
now I gotta do the show now I got a big
name I just gotta find a venue and I and
I had the band already they were on hold
just doing their own [ __ ] and then I
literally stumbled into the lyric which
is the old venue we used to do it at and
it just it was just like everything
about that show has been perfect it is
just we haven't changed it the first
show is exactly like the show I do now
two years later it's the same format
same band this I've added a couple
players to it but it just runs like
clockwork man it's great so much fun
2010 2009 I was living in Hollywood and
confused like everybody else a next
level do I get a day job
thousand [ __ ] dilemmas
one of the things I was thinking about
Josh Adam Meyers was that what is a
miracle I get sick and tired of marching
three comics I'm a comic and I'm telling
you this from my perspective when is
America gonna get sick and tired I gonna
show or watching three comics I know
something has to happen and a bunch of
things not that I created them in my
mind I just always said wow it would be
interesting to see something else well I
saw you know there was a couple shows I
saw that were different you know how he
did the storytelling is enough yet and I
saw the pictures from you a burn I
giggled I go this might [ __ ] work I
said it but I saw burr
yeah I go this might work because I get
what he's doing
you know we're all 50% of comics they
just not failed musicians maybe aspiring
musician then we figured out that he got
a guitar one the pointing at 10 times so
we can never be consistent with it yeah
that was my thing how would he got a
guitar but I know I was not born with a
pond at eight times
let's show W kaleil you got fired you
know [ __ ] like that
I'm really happy that this worked like
I'm [ __ ] his thank you very much then
you called me it was Super Bowl Sunday
we couldn't get our dates together
because the was it I've been trying to
get I know I've been trying to get you
on for a while and this I think it was
we had you on another date and then the
day got moved or something no football
they didn't wanna rehearse on Super Bowl
Sunday so Monday we figured let's just
it was February 4th or something right
okay and then you asked me if I could do
the 28th I was out of town the 28th and
then I bumped that then the soul the
show soul I could tell you overwhelmed
you were very overwhelmed I had read
that soul and when I read the sold I was
so happy I was happy for you but I was
happy for comedy because you know it
this is what we needed we need something
different we need
this is what makes you stronger as
economic is going to different avenues
ensure the central focus is still comedy
it's like I'm going from football to
[ __ ] baseball well you know it's it's
you you still going it like people ask
me it's like like you know so it's like
a music shop I say it's a comedy to
commercial for my [ __ ] up cuz I love
was a story somebody telling a lot of
states what was the story towards that
song you just like all right let's do
this [ __ ] yeah no but it's it's
like and that was my bags I couldn't
explain it more but I remembered that
you had mentioned that was what you
wanted to do it I always want the comics
within their wheelhouse of what they
feel comfortable doing and it's always
perfect for you made your own okay so
it's that it's what you're supposed to
do eight minutes to stand up tell the
story just relate to the audience why
you chose it and I figured I didn't you
I wasn't watching six oh no I was doing
[ __ ] stupid jokes up down a Monday
but let me I gotta tell you something I
had cold feet that afternoon you know
even though I had I couldn't rehearse
the song in the shower even though I'd
written the lyrics and all that stuff
I'm like I'm not [ __ ] he decked up
two hits on that but the funniest thing
was I get a little bling xiety in the
store when I walk up the steps to the or
okay I always get a little touch of
anxiety sometimes have to actually sit
down and do breathing exercises I see
the light go on and it gives me more
anxiety when the song started I don't
know have you noticed I was looking at
the drummer for a reason because it was
coming on big time I thought I was gonna
pass out I stated when I turned around
and saw all those people it was real it
reminded me of a marquee Wahlberg got
hit in the head and that movie man as a
singer Oh rock star right on the first
number the first [ __ ] song he did he
got hit in the [ __ ] head and he fell
down he looked at the audience and they
were blurry that's what I was saying
when I turned the first time and so if
you would have been next to me I would
have gone down like a [ __ ] ton of
bricks you killed it I would have gone
down but it was I was very anxious up
there I couldn't breathe I couldn't
catch my the songs got eight lyrics no I
know
it's got four different
enough to sing it it's literally just
you say it it was perfect you chose the
perfect song yeah no it was perfect you
made your own especially when you were
like you know you're like now they do
what you do what is it now you do it now
I do what is it I can't look at the
label I tell you yeah
now they do what you tell you just he
was so Joey doing it just like nag you
know you're just so [ __ ] good man top
five like you caused a riot dude I was a
[ __ ] riot I had so much [ __ ]
anxiety that night like you came no idea
where my anxiety was in the middle
that's all if you wouldn't I kept
looking at ya and looking back at the
drama like I was making believe I was
having a good time with the drummer no
cuz every time I look at that audience
my head would spin o-360 I'm sorry
that's your fault at all not your fault
at all I don't know what it but it you
know what even at the 25 year mark yeah
it's great to still have that fear
before you go onstage that's you know
what's your you just go home and pack it
up that's what that's what BER we open
for so November last year we did
Gramercy Theatre in New York we did the
jam there Bert was on that and then the
next day before he did Madison Square
Garden we went in June he rented a bunch
of instruments the drum set and all the
[ __ ] we played at Madison Square Garden
for like three hours and then we did and
then we all hung out watches his set
and afterwards he had this huge party
and I was saying goodbye after chilling
for a while and he goes and I said to
thank you so much dude like everything
you does but it was actually on my
birthday - I was like it's been the best
birthday of my life man hands down this
is one for the ages and he's like he
goes now man thank you and I'm like why
and he goes because of your show the
night before in front of 700 people I
wasn't nervous to perform in front of
14,000 do you know what I mean
be and that's the cool thing is like
that you've been doing this for so long
and people like burned and you know and
and just just everybody that's done the
show like you will get nervous doing
this because they while you're
performing there's that ticking clock in
your head like all [ __ ] dude I gotta I
gotta sing known under by men at work
goddamn
yeah but it's but the thing is like it's
not something to be nervous about
because the crowd is so supportive
they're not they don't want to see you
fail like dude and like we've had people
like we call it like you know when you
win you Jay Larson the song which is you
know Jay Jay [ __ ] the first time he
did the show he did the show the first
show was Matt Braunger Jay Larson Ryan
Sickler and then then Burr and Jay went
up second and I wrong or want goes up
first and I'm like I don't think this is
gonna work man like the crowd seemed
like they're into it but they're not
standing it just seemed really weird and
the Jay went up and he did messaging
about oh by the police right and he dude
everything about that song like he
[ __ ] it up like he was singing the
verse during the chorus and the chorus
turned the verse he was all over the
place and the crowd just started singing
with him to get him back in the right
place but the whole time he's up there
just bobbing and dancing and going crazy
and committing to it and that was when I
knew this show was gonna work because
the crowd went [ __ ] bananas so they
nobody's eating [ __ ] on it not one
person so not one person since we
thought they care about you guys and
they love you they're your fans they
come out here to see you do this and so
they get excited when they know you're
gonna be on it because they want to see
what you're gonna do and they know
you're not gonna be Whitney Houston on
the goddamn [ __ ] thing they
know that it's gonna be your version of
it and that's why it's cool you know how
did this show how did this show get the
air a doozy to get on television yeah
for me to see how well the show is in
two years it was it's been two years
from the first show do we got well I
sold it I've sold it twice so I do the
show we do the first show Ryan Sickler
does that show Ryan is one of my best
friends he calls me like a week or so
later he's like did I so much fun thank
you for having me on it I got this guy I
want you to meet the Duffy's right they
have a production company and I told him
about your show and they want to sit
down and talk to you about turning into
a TV show and like after the first one
everybody was like oh there's gonna be a
TV show it's gonna be a TV show that's
not why I started I started because it's
fun
so we we do I go and take the meeting
with the Duffy's and they're like all
about it and so they're like we're gonna
come out and shoot it and then we're
gonna do like a sizzle reel for it so
they did that we signed an agreement
like so that was July 2014 we signed an
agreement in December 2014 we sold it on
our first pitch to CW which was like for
me I was like this I was like we walked
into it this is our throwaway pitch this
is that we do not expect them to buy
it's literally practice for us we went
in there
the Duffy's talked and then that was it
I had it a few like him then they could
do this and then they could do this but
I was like totally nervous is the first
time I ever pitch to show to a big
network regardless if it's a throw away
and then a week later they're like yeah
we want to do a pilot with you and they
then held the show hostage for that was
CW CW held a hostage for probably like
five months where they they were like
you know we make we sign the deal with
them and then we were getting ready to
shoot it and it literally went from one
dude who bought it then he had to take
it and then pitch it again to his boss
he loved it and then we had to go to the
head of the network to Mark Pedowitz and
Pedowitz didn't like it he was like I
don't really see it working and that was
it hmm so we got it back before Montreal
2015 and everybody there dude it was
just a hit of the festival we were it
was like literally there was our show in
roast battle and that was that
everything else was like secondary and
we had Burrell on it and every show was
sold out and we just me and the band
just [ __ ] brought it we knew it we
knew how big of an opportunity this was
really we're performing for every buyer
like every television network and every
show he treated it like it was the
biggest show in our lives like as we do
even the ones out here I mean we really
just commit to everything so we did the
show we got back in the Comedy Central
wanted a meeting in like September and
we sit in the meeting and it's like Gary
and Jonas and all the dudes and [ __ ]
the Duffy's talked for like two minutes
and then
I was like I've got this I just felt so
comfortable in the room because I was
like this is the network I want to be at
we were already getting offers for other
networks that was the one I wanted them
or HBO but really Comedy Central because
that's where I'm show interest and HBO
never really was into it but also it's
it was just I think they weren't trying
to do stand-up related stuff so but
Comedy Central has always been my number
one like that was the one I want the
only Comedy Network and I want to
[ __ ] be in that family I want to be
able to hang out with the South Park
guys if I can go to the PI you know what
I mean that's what I want and we went in
that room they talked the Duffy's talked
for a few minutes and then I was like I
got this and then I just sold that show
in the room they bought it like
literally two days later then we're like
we want to do a special a narrable
special so like an hour which will be a
backdoor into a series that was November
when we found out you know and then you
[ __ ] it's then it's like all that
time of pre-production I mean so we they
bought it we the deal was signed to
beginning of January and we didn't
[ __ ] actually shoot it until June
21st time I wanted that money dude
[ __ ] like I got to buy a new mattress
dude like tell me what kind of get like
is this gonna happen is it isn't and it
just what's been good is that the
network is behind it they made some
changes to it that I understand they're
doing for they did for the special like
it's not exactly what we do with the
live show it's not as wild my part got
severely reduced for that but when it
goes to series like there's a lot more
that we're gonna do it and then we're
gonna bring it back to what the show
actually is do you know what I mean the
special was released a couple weeks ago
it was released August 28th there's a
day before you did the show gotta go
look great I mean it was it was on after
the VMAs and the VMAs ran long so a lot
of the numbers kind of got messed up but
for 12 a.m. at night we got good numbers
and like social media wise it was
incredible and what's the other should
social media like he just got it I got a
shitload of you digital through digital
shake out a lot of views so so it's it's
done very well but now we're just
waiting we're waiting to find out if we
get a series but I mean every arrow is
pointing to yes I don't see why they
wouldn't give it a see
you know because I'm getting fun I will
get like 10 Wow
yeah well the deal is for six but I
could see it go I can see them buy it so
it's cheaper to make more you know what
I mean than just six we're gonna do six
you might as well make ten it's only
gonna be like a couple like hundred
thousand dollars we want things if
you're gonna do six more main lines like
a blue three a night there's no way I
could ship that dude I mean knowing that
we might even do two in one night that
I'll [ __ ] kill num be on prednisone
and [ __ ] yeah I'll be there every
anti-inflammatory they'll give you one
week on that like some [ __ ] could
Myka I just did a friend of mine she'll
he was like we shot nine episodes in one
week is that Ari no this is for a helmet
planet okay no I'm [ __ ] episode
someone we guess everything animals I
know he killed me like start on [ __ ]
Monday and rap on Sunday with a party
that would kill me just even doing the
one like the one like I excited vocal
cord surgery February I had a nodule
take it off my vocal cords cuz my cords
were just [ __ ] up ma'am 36 you get to
an age it just starts giving out and
then I vape like a dumb [ __ ] you know
what I mean well not anymore but I say I
did four years I smoke weed smoke
cigarettes and then I quit that I
started vaping and the baiban [ __ ] my
foot yeah it my throat every time I vape
I could I could I think it's worse than
it's definite for people that talk all
the time yes if you use your voice
that's the worst thing you can do and I
mean I I've ate for four years and then
the second I quit they got better like
they were inflamed and go the doctor
he'd scoped my throat stick the thing
down look at it and he'd be like dude
what the [ __ ] are you doing and I'm just
like nothing I'm just just vape and he's
like you didn't got it stop doing this
[ __ ] him I did I can't man I love the
taste of Froot Loops cereal milk him
alone this manly with the horrible you
know I mean it's like that was a sort of
a for a long time and then I quit and so
we got to do this special my I had are
still vaping but I just took like you
know prednisone was like a miracle drug
for singers man like prednisone decadron
so I went that morning I got a shot from
the ENT took a couple prednisone and
then whether it slipped the shot for you
for your knee ass they give it a sore
shoulder for your vocal cords my vocal
cords what's a steroid
like it's it's like this right like see
what really happened was so I did when
we did jfl in 2015 right like I was
DJing at a strip club so every Thursday
every Friday I'm on the mic [ __ ] you
know eight hour shifts we start getting
closer and closer to to the shows in
Montreal and I know how big a deal this
is so what I started doing was taking
like care of myself where I wouldn't go
out at night like I would do show and
I'd go home and then I was like you know
I got to start resting my voice right
guys start taking like like you know
supplements like little mints not mints
but these like little drops for your
throat when I went to the doctor and
then they I don't know where I just lost
my voice I lost my voice like a week
before we took off and it would not come
back
I went got shots for it it would not
come back so I go to the doctor he goes
listen you know he's like you got a
nodule on your vocal cords but that's
not the reason it's super inflamed right
now so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
give you a bunch of these medication
give me prednisone and I'm gonna give
you a couple shots before you leave and
he goes in that'll pace so basically
we're just gonna put a bandaid on your
cords and we'll deal with the problem
when you come back so it's like it's
like Emmitt Smith like you know
fracturing his shoulder or like blowing
his knee out and I'll get the playoffs
and they're like dude you know you got
to win this game so here's a cortisone
shot here's some percocet go out there
and win the game and that's what I did
but by doing that I made my cords way
worse so it was like when I came back to
the states it was like a full that was
July my cords didn't get better until -
March April actually April's when I
started singing again and it sounded
good April of 2016 so I was tough man
who shot the pilot what stars shot the
pilot well who was on it yeah that's Mel
picture you were nothing better so I
thought Eddie thought it was oh no no no
that was in Bonnaroo that was the Music
Festival Bonnaroo we had Pete Davidson
from Saturday Night Live Jay Ferrel from
Saturday Night Live Jim Jeffries Natasha
Leggero and Adam Devine oh I thought you
had like a [ __ ] Led Zep on the studio
dude now it's well here's what's cool so
I thought dude I'm telling you like I so
the special airs and I'm getting calls
from like huge comics right from not
just comics but comedic actors like
people that want to do this are like
dude I want to do this song with this
singer like and I
I'm friends with this guy we can make
this happen we got people that want to
do [ __ ] with Metallica like it could
what's cool it's like this is the thing
it's like why wouldn't you give me a
season of it
because like there's so much cool [ __ ]
that we do we add Coolio on the first
[ __ ] thing and we can do way better
than Coolio you know what I mean like we
can get [ __ ] you know we'll reunite
[ __ ] the band heart and get [ __ ]
Wilson Phillips like it's just gonna
grow and grow and that's what's
happening in LA
organically we're getting real rock
stars I want to do it now that we move
into the Roxy like that immediately
validates it where everybody's like well
this is the place if they don't have the
rock scene has got to be legit you know
what I mean like the month before we had
we had some guys from Velvet Revolver
there we had Jon Theodore from Queens of
the Stone Age we had Dave Kushner then
we had John Mayer's just chilling John
Mayer we just came to the show just to
hang out the one is seeing you perform
and now he wants to do it like
organically it's just gonna grow and
turn into something really fun cool
music one big question I got a short for
TV purposes how there are just a number
of songs you could do now we get we can
get whatever you want that's the cool
yeah dude it's like they spent a lot of
money on this man yeah yeah yeah and
it's not even the like we did we ending
it with we are the champions and that's
like cheap like certain songs that you
would think would be expensive or
actually cheap I mean there's like
there's like from what I know like Led
Zeppelin's kind of off the table Beatles
are off the table and Michael Jackson
but if somebody big enough wanted to do
it they pay you know what I mean you
know if [ __ ] it if we can get you know
cuz that's the thing it's like I think
when it goes to serious like we're gonna
get some really really big names you
know what I mean and I'm glad it's on
Comedy Central and not CW because CW
would have [ __ ] it up yeah they will
put buffy the vampire ice singing no
diggity like
you know it's it's we can get real
comics I mean look at burr we'll get
Sarah Silverman I mean we had louis c.k
come and sit down and do the show I'm
trying to get your boy Jojo scared
shitless you need to tell that mother
about gonna do it I want him to do it
he'd be the best at it do another
goddamn Rage Against the Machine song
he's just screaming you know what I mean
that's all you did you [ __ ] but you
did you did sing a little bit melody I
couldn't think listen I couldn't think
of another song
there was one of the song you and I
discussed no it was always always a jump
from jumpy because I said I want you to
do the show you go you go killing in the
name of like immediately you said that
and I was again that's it that was why
when I got you to finally commit to
doing this one I immediately just said
you want to still do killing in the name
of you like yeah that was it I don't
really usually like I'll call people and
I'll be like what are you thinking about
like like I I know what will work people
will give me a song that I'm like why
would you pick this you know and even
like a huge comic so give me a song it's
so random and I'm like dude nobody's
gonna know this like no it's got to be a
hit can't be a b-side can't be a deep
album cut and most people are super cool
now that they realize that I know what
will work you know what I mean I knew
immediately you would have been the
first person to do killing in the name
of because we waited so long I had John
doar do it because he had picked it and
I mean but nobody did it the way you did
it I mean you know what the next old
lady do girls just want to have fun
that's my jam every time I hear the end
of that I could tell she's having such a
great know what the [ __ ] she's saying at
the end of that song by still remember
coming from Colorado to New York the
girl that had a crush on yeah like that
song and it was like killing me like
really girls just want to have fun what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
till I saw the video but I like to saw
like every time I hear that song I think
of that summer this is a good that's a
good source well a little unless you've
seen that she's really good in concert
Cyndi Lauper yeah [ __ ] yeah I've heard
it 30,000 they say she's [ __ ]
hysterical
they all got chops man I saw Billy Joel
not too long ago and then [ __ ]
a half-hour of solid material like solid
and then I saw them like two nights
later he did the same bits and they kill
dude so rock stars they all got Joe
y'all got jokes call him between the
jams everybody I was reading a thing on
on in Rolling Stone magazine is Adele
you know the big lake
you know soul singer from Britain right
now so she does an hour-and-a-half show
right she sings for 40 minutes and then
talks for 30 you know I mean that's her
show they broke it down to see like who
talks the most and given between she's
got 30 minutes of material to they all
they it's literally all they do are they
trying to make you laugh or like stories
about the songs are a little bit of both
but I think it's I think also it's like
they they want it to be funny you know
what I mean like new comedians and rock
stars it's just there's a weird a weird
thing about it like if you've ever hung
out with like a rock star right somebody
that made it then it would be a rock
star but just so many that's that's
professional musician whatever year or
however old they were when they made it
is what what maturity level they'll
stuck at does that make sense you know
Tommy Lee the guys from like they're
stuck at that age they're stuck at like
17 18 years old they might have millions
of dollars but they're still [ __ ] and
Tommy Lee every time I've seen them it's
like he's 18 yeah he's like super
immature so yeah bro nah dude it's like
dude you're [ __ ] 53 now I'm good you
know what I mean there's it's just
there's something about it I've met a
lot of rock stars recently where I
started hanging out with and I'm like
dude you're [ __ ] I mean they're
they're mature but they're still they
just have that like I don't know how to
explain just their whole air about them
is that there's still kids because they
never had to grow up you know what I
mean I'd be that way too I did music my
whole life if I would have made it one
of my bands I'd be stuck at like 23 and
I just lived that 23 year old lifestyle
in my head but chill just pay my bills
and do this [ __ ] that adults do but
still talk like a 23 year old just you
know what I mean dressed like it do
Tommy Lee still dressed like a
[ __ ] that's 18 years old he's
just on 2016's level of 18 now so the
clothes are a little bit you know
updated it's not wearing you can't
really wear spandex you know a cheetah
spandex anymore and still if I can be
cool you know like when Kennesaw was at
the store
doing that kind of stuff they saying
wild thing with Rudy Sarzo and a bunch
of the people and if so we had that
connection wasn't as much as that
connection was more cocaine oh yeah
what's those [ __ ] videos with poison
and Kennison and they'll tell you how
[ __ ] up they were and stuff like that
but I've always you know I've been a no
but it's so weird how they'll talk to
you I was on a plane with [ __ ]
Sebastian and John Legend I was we were
all normal and Sebastian Bach or
Sebastian well escapo was sitting next
to me and lunch on legend was sitting
next to me on this side so John Legend
me and then there was a while and then
it was Sebastian I'm sitting there John
Legend tips is heavenly goes hey I saw
your special I really liked it and he is
too bad this guy talking with Sebastian
general allegedly by the special now he
watched it he wants it three times an
hour about and it's so weird I think
sometimes it's a mutual admiration oh
for sure it's a definite mutual
admiration because they know how hard is
to get up on this we know how hard it is
you know what that stand-up comics of
rock stars man that is to be to be like
just shred like slash is one of the most
you know difficult things you can do you
can learn how to play guitar too but to
be able to have the feel and really just
lay it out there in the music that
you're playing I mean that's incredible
and what we're doing is is honestly just
as hard if not harder to go into a room
full of strangers to come up with
something to say and that's original and
[ __ ] make people laugh you know so it
just it's just blend seamlessly together
well that's why this show works I think
it's because you've taken something and
you just both taking both those worlds
and putting together and then also the
main thing is both things we're doing
are super fun other people want to do it
everybody wants to do what we're doing
everybody always thinks they can be a
stand-up comic or they get it I gotta be
in the band you don't even know I'm
still in a band it's like yeah it's just
me and the other dads in the
neighborhood but we're killing it in a
garage you know I realized why
lip-synching
is [ __ ] so
relevant in comedy when he landed that
night you know if you know about like
the wall those were those singers that
move a lot like Janet Jackson the
beginning on her tour she lip-synchs
tempest oh yeah it looks it's 90% black
as you could cardio and anxiety and all
that [ __ ] I've never seen anybody sweat
as much as you did during that so my god
you were drenched I was an anxiety
attack it just it just can't I was like
a skunk yeah a little bit of sweat came
out from every [ __ ] orifice and as
soon as I went up there I felt it I knew
it was gonna happen but I gotta tell you
something but I'll tell you to your face
I think I told me that they have to it
I've missed that much fun on stage thank
you all [ __ ] time you [ __ ] count do
you care the show I haven't had that
much fun in a long goddamn time but I
left there and my mind was kind of blown
like I had to go home and think through
it thought the pipe and go what just
[ __ ] happened jack what just [ __ ]
happened them you know that was too much
and it was so well documented to did so
many people recorded that so you get to
just relive it over and over well I've
watched it like 79 I've watched like
half of it to shut it off I don't even
get to the [ __ ] you I won't do either
parts at the end cuz I guess that's one
cuz he gets he gets at least like six
inches off the ground when he chose my
favorite part is the middle finger of
the indigent less and here's my question
yeah I always hear a lot from comics
like if you have like you hear about a
comic who maybe has like a whole the
whole set is like jokey Sorrows
mm-hmm it gets a little bit looked down
upon but everyone loves this show like
where do you think the difference is
because it it's a little similar but
like there's like everyone what this
show is amazing it was the first time
I'd been to it and like it was a great
like I'll go next time as a fan please
you're always invited as a fan because I
want to see now you're in the goddamn
Comedy Jam rock and roll ha ha yeah I
know you sandy about about the you know
cause like when you go see like comedy
music or musicians that are comics that
do music in that sense like the songs
are usually cheesie's [ __ ] you know what
I mean it's usually like if it girls
doing it it's always like you know this
is talking about my boyfriend or giving
blood
and it's like don't forget about the
balls don't forget about the balls when
you're giving a hand actually wheezes
right pretty melodic rich thanks me
write that down
that [ __ ] drives me crazy yeah and you
want to be [ __ ] what's his name sign
up what's a guy that spooks all the song
The Weird Al Yankovic
we still buys music he's just well he I
think a lot of people still [ __ ] with it
because of the movie UHF you know maybe
you ever seen UHF long time ago movies
great I still quote it you know what I
mean so I don't think he's getting new
fans I think he's just got the people
from a long time ago I don't forget new
fans oh man what was I might be wrong
yeah well the last time he released
about came out with this but that's I
think it's the people [ __ ] 10 fans or
actually when I was in Montreal 2015 he
did a free concert outside and it was
[ __ ] bananas packed just packed so so
so calm music musicians or no musicians
comics that do music is like there's not
many that have like there's Tenacious D
that are taken seriously that are cool
because their whole act is this thing
their songs aren't funny they're
actually really good songs you know I
mean like me a band like we have a bunch
of originals too that are super funny
but they're like they're real rock songs
and they're super catchy we don't try to
make people laugh throughout the song
through the lyrics we just just from
what we do in it it's just we take that
we take it so seriously but it's like
completely a farce whereas I think the
show is successful is because of what
Joey just said he hasn't had that much
fun and you god knows how long
you're having fun then the audience is
having fun do you know what I mean what
we created is just it's an event it's
like it's just like a feeling you know
what I mean you come to the show every
show is like that I mean it's just we
don't take it too seriously it's it's
literally just supposed to be a bunch of
people gonna laugh or a little bit
you're gonna rock out for a little bit
and it's all ages oh it's ever dude that
was all the people there that was young
the people yeah I thought it was gonna
be a bunch of uber people you know like
young kid twenty-four year old boy was I
shot did it's huge and that was like cuz
we were going up against
there was another festival going on and
that was the first one we hadn't
completely sold out like it was like it
was close to it but like usually we have
like somebody said one of the one of the
Booker's for the New York Comedy
Festival said my show has the highest
faked it to regular ratio we have the
most with fake boobs at our show which
is a good thing to have I think that's I
like that you know what I mean out of
every show they don't get that
accomodate usually 700 people New York
and places like that in in New York we
Gramercy we sold out that was like 750
in LA we're getting about 400 now moving
into the Roxy which is great we've got
you know it just depends on the on the
festival and the venue but we show on
the road we're doing extremely well with
you know I mean I love it I gotta be
honest with you about one thing what's
happened don't get offended please I
like what you did I don't like when
people [ __ ] sang [ __ ] they [ __ ]
sold mm-hmm like if you think I'm picky
about food [ __ ] with me about music jack
[ __ ] with my world of music because I'll
even pick it I get pissed
what would they do you mean like I'm Way
older than you when I was a kid there
was jaws and there was something else
there was spoof songs so what you did
was you took the best of the summer
songs and you wrote a story about it so
did you see the shark what did you tell
him please mister please and then oh my
god he's coming into the kitchen and
they would do it look at the jaws to
spoof song from the 70s see if it's on
that John Smith song yeah from the 70s
like they did [ __ ] like that that was
cue for a while they did them terribly
burnt the [ __ ] out Dickie Goodwin
yeah Dickie Goodman mr. Torres yeah
let's see let's hear this
this is a mr. Jose how was it and what
did she say when you grabbed her
I know sharks are stupid but what did
you think when you took that first fight
mr. Jose before you swim out to sea have
you anything else to say
I got was pen they were cute
we'll be back what do you intend to do
get down the night just arriving is
oceanographer Matt Hooper sir if someone
is attacked by a shark the fishing boat
captain Quint captain with this popular
[ __ ] thing
huge the number one in execute took the
Beatles off number one what's that it
keeps going oh yeah yeah you get to the
chorus it's over how long the captain
says he's going to catch you
what do you think of that oh here he
comes again I can't believe people
bought this this was a this is like
Homer it was from mr. jaws why are you
grabbing my hand
[Music]
so they had a sample that music you let
the Eagles 10cc everybody this guy stole
more than rappers he's got everybody out
here he's the he's the car they make a
family they can't they made like three
of these and then they want to put were
you just like on their Wikipedia page
not too long no no no I just was
thinking about an animal thing on my
calming music about a year two three
years ago Eddie Brown when Rogen after a
comedy show said let's go see steel
dragon
I left that for the second of so don't
disrespect them they're nice guys they
invited this I met them I can't tolerate
that [ __ ] I think that's the shipping
but it's it's not like this isn't my
this isn't like supposed to be funny
it's supposed to be like no we don't
want like I don't want like if you want
to make it funny you can't in the crowd
will love it regardless but it's like
when you do that what's cool about it is
like they they never get to see they get
to see an honest side of you absolutely
you know what I mean because you can't
hide it behind you jokes you gotta
[ __ ] perform that so when somebody
goes up there and they do it man you
know the crowd gets to see you in a
vulnerable position and that's what's a
beautiful thing you know what I mean it
takes it takes Joey Diaz from Joey Diaz
from uncle Joey and makes him just
[ __ ] Joey Diaz the most important
thing about that bunk it was a lefty
that's the first time I left bong get
lefty and it worked first time no
[ __ ] practice you understand good I
shot all that basketball as a youngster
you mentioned your boy I knew you guys
were tight to just start together and
both knew cyclic cyclic brassiere ayan
Ryan I met I running that out here I met
Ryan
at The Improv one night one of my first
real shows like doing a real set of The
Improv remember Darrell right black
black Missy I have no idea man I heard
he was in Vegas he's doing a NASCAR shot
with Jay more than I see jmontie we
doing the Rams I have no idea Darrell
just disappeared Darrell was like the
second coming in The Improv he was up
there like every night and then he just
disappeared but he's to do a show called
ignorance is bliss
he did that The Improv Ryan goes up does
a set and immediately I remember he
mentions from Maryland and I'm like holy
[ __ ] so after the [ __ ] said I just go up
I started talking to him and immediately
hit it off and he's kind of like my Yoda
you know what I mean like I'll call him
when I have when I need advice or I need
an opinion about something and comedy
related and what's funny is I teased him
about this like anytime you asked for
his opinion like yeah this dude he's
like telling me to do this and I don't
want to do this I'm a little because
every time you go up and done it yeah
yeah and it's vibrate so he'll I I mean
I can't my agent wants me to do this
thing I know if I want to do it and
every response that Ryan gives me is you
know what you got told that dude you
tell that dude to go [ __ ] himself
you tell him go [ __ ] himself every
advice always ends now man tell that
person to go [ __ ] himself like that is
all the only advice is good for most
time he's right I'm not gonna lie but
he's good he's got a kid now and I
talked him almost every day he was up
for show he's a producer on the on the
Comedy Jam television show because he
brought it and he's the story producer
so he works with the comics to kind of
like tighten everything and he's great
he's the best man you know I mean I
think you know what it is you meet
somebody that's from the same area you
grew up you gonna [ __ ] it stick together
and many we met vows I got it we will be
friends well totally better it's Monday
September 19th a beautiful [ __ ] week
you
oh [ __ ] I love the first versa ah it
always makes me cry oh that's one of
those actually you talk about cry boo
Tony Bennett is he did smile you do that
song yeah you know smile if your heart
is raining again I do kick this
[ __ ] Lee we didn't finish it's
Monday what do you turn it off for you
need a barn Emily you need to think that
sweating again
you haven't stopped [ __ ] fidgety I'll
never stop sweating fidgeting touching
the water I couldn't believe it before
you
this panel is [ __ ] smokin kick it Lee
sweet
you
and beautiful Monday September 19th Tony
Bennett taking you [ __ ] to the hoop
[ __ ] Lee didn't grow up a music
guy it's really no you're like what did
you grow up listening to do it know
anything it's kind of random like my
parents my mom like just like show tunes
and like oldies sort of and what she
grew up with and my dad was like sort of
disco a he where he worked in nightclubs
he liked a lot of disco and so I just
never really got in like into anything
and like all my friends in like middle
school started getting into like the
Beatles and Dave met Dave now how are
you I'm 28 I know I'm here but I'm only
20 um
I was gonna say you were like all my
friends start getting into Beatles I was
like how have no hold of this dude no no
I'm not that old but uh yeah I don't
know I just never I went to like my
first old radio never had one but I ever
really use it it was weird I have a
friend like that that it's so weird you
know his house you know for years I
always noticed there was something
missing he never had a boombox never had
like I asked him once I go you don't
have music and and he goes I have music
in my office you know it's what I use it
for a sports radio that's what I used
mostly dude music and comedy have been
in my life I could pinpoint points in my
life through songs and through calm well
we all have a personal thing yeah but
not just that but I mean I can remember
the first time I saw Carlin heck on
comic relief like I 6 years old what was
your first comic that you saw was George
Carlin that was when I wanted to walk
him and Garry Shandling is the first
real introduction to stand-up comedy was
my dad was watching comic relief on HBO
you know and that was the that was where
Carlin did my stuff is stuff your stuff
is [ __ ] and I was like that's so cool
man like I want to do that about as I
get it no you got to be a little older
blah blah blah but I grew up in a
musical household so that was what I was
doing
from like three on I always had
instruments in front of me so I remember
that mmm who played instruments in
Europe my dad and my well not so much my
mom and my dad really and then once I
got into like elementary school that was
kind of like my interest so they get me
into trumpet and my dad got me a guitar
piano drums and then when I got into my
like teens that was when I started like
you know go out of the house start
smoking weed guys formed a band
what were they listening to those dude I
don't like that all right
this is dude I'm you would you play a
Tony Bennett [ __ ] like you understand
man like I'm one of the luckiest people
in the world my father introduced me to
everything dope and an early age you
know what I mean how well I mean six
years old I was when I got in my first
of all he had like the Richard Pryor
record so I used to like steal them and
put them on I was always grew up around
jazz like Joe Pass on guitar or like you
know
Miles Davis Charlie Parker Coltrane
Thelonious Monk kills every Bill Evans
Dave Brubeck I mean Frank Sinatra I mean
Mel Torme whatever dude it was just
constant music playing in my house the
four freshmen just my dad listened to
everything but also like movies I
remember like at eight years old
watching like rebel without a cause or
like Mel Brooks like history of the
world part one when I was like before I
was ten
you know so I was introduced to so much
cool [ __ ] my mom was more like more of
the Beatles and more the rock stuff but
you know my mom my mom my dad was cool
and then he had me and then I took all
the cool from the rock stuff your mom
was a more like you know Baba's and
Papa's Jefferson Airplane [ __ ] like
that's my pop you know that that
quantumly you just don't wanna
well I'd sell over those mics Bolton
before you blow out all our [ __ ]
earphones here my my dad I don't have
you ever smoke grass my mom always used
to talk about she'd be like you know
when I was younger
she's got that like cigarette smoking
mom voice like when I was younger I
smoked hashish with this is really Rock
store and and that's kinda the last time
I did it I actually got high with my mom
back in 2003 or 2004 she had a bad back
we went to the
she sure she's like yeah the vicodins
not working and I was like smoking
blunts I was dating this girl she taught
me how to roll blunts and that was I
really got into like smoking blunts by
myself
and my mom it was in the hotel room my
dad my sister left and I was like my I
was like it was like Mary mentioned
you're in pain I was like if I said I
had weed would you smoke with me and
she's like I'll try anything and then me
and her smoked had blood together and it
was it was an experience yeah I mean we
just sat there and giggled
but she's never smoked it again and you
know super super square man my parents
were very I was that I was like kind of
like their first dose into a lot of
problems sisters I got a sister perfect
kid never got in trouble she's a doctor
lives in the Eastern Shore now Maryland
her husband's like the district attorney
for the county they live in super white
man super did you talk with her do I
talk my time yeah I mean you know she's
she's got a bunch of kids like I would
call I call her all the time but like
when I say all the time it's like once a
month and we talk for a little bit and I
go and visit when I can but she's come
out and supported me for a lot of things
in my life you know what I mean she came
out for we did the Kennedy Center we did
the cod AM Comedy Jam at the Kennedy
Center she came out for that we played
the show at the black cat DC you know
probably like six months early she's
come out for that she wanted to come out
for the TV taping but she was just tied
up with the kids so she couldn't but
she's she's great man
you know she's always supported me I
think it's kind of like I always looked
up to her because she was like book
smart not saying I'm not book smart but
definitely I appreciate anybody that can
[ __ ] take their you know their MCATs
and [ __ ] ace it you know and study
you know like organic chemistry and [ __ ]
like that so I respect her but she also
respects me that I'm more street smart
and also able to do what I can do you
know what I mean it's it's the same
thing like it's just I wish I had what
she had she wishes I had she has what I
had and it just it's kind of a cool
blend so before to a young man
everything when we first got here were
talking about drugs and I said to you
that
when I got the know surgery and she said
she was only giving me something when I
got to the [ __ ] pharmacy they pulled
me over now I listen she gave me
something really [ __ ] strong now
right at that point I'm excited when
they pull you over like to say listen
what we're giving you is really [ __ ]
this is some good [ __ ] I'm gonna get a
lockbox I'm like okay so I'm getting
excited for the surgery now
even with my addictive ways I didn't
take one before the surgery you know
they want you to have him a week before
the surge yeah I don't mean because I
heard oxys are really addicting I had
done an oxy cotton maybe 2007 right when
I was at the end of blo that year when
we don't heroin on Mondays to snort to
come down off the coat somebody gave me
a piece of a red pill they said it was a
relaxing I popped it and within [ __ ]
10 minutes I had to lay down my world
was rocked that was my blood pressure
drop
I felt like puking and then when I got
the surgical unit oxycottons what the
lady told me they're pretty [ __ ] deep
let's try them you know I'm home I got
the week is clear sure and I [ __ ] did
the prescribed dose the first day one
there before I was cuz I'm scared to I
don't know Michael Jackson that bag I
got the baby mm-hmm
[ __ ] did [ __ ] you up at all no 25
milligrams
that'll level that's that's the next day
pop three at one time no wonder Michael
Jackson is so I'm just gonna take four
of them but what I did was by the end of
I called the friend and he goes no I
know you're a long time nicotine yeah
another grand oh this was a couple I
usually pop two boys listen though you
pop two boys with a cup of coffee
Cuban coffee in the morning Oh dolly
that's like the nicotine gum when I
first pulled what's he doing because we
you a Marc Maron hooked on nicotine
Marc Maron eats them all [ __ ] that
all of us our kidneys are gonna blow off
the one that my
I've been chewing nicotine gum for
[ __ ] six months now I started that
one for now I'm popping two at a time
two fours with a cup of coffee you're
off and running Jack they stop me I've
been telling people he is they don't
have a foul oh I quit I quit vaping and
immediately just I'm addicted to the
nicotine you go to CVS you know i go to
i go to costco dude 50-piece no you get
fifty dollars for a two hundred pieces
you cannot buy a nicotine gum ik at
[ __ ] Costco you ain't doing it right
no those changes world right now CVS got
that Mexican [ __ ] guy oh if it
doesn't say Nicorette on it listen to me
now if you just say before I got five my
buddies gave me some Mexican Nicorette
you have no [ __ ] PP you pop two of
those and they're 16-ounce when they
call it what's the second coffee at
Starbucks when the dementing go and then
get a venti and pop two of those and get
back to me you will get regular oh my
god dude I look forward to it in the
morning like I'll have my cup of coffee
and I won't have my first piece I start
moving my bowels moving like I time to
pop over I get on the toilet you can't
[ __ ] you pop a cup of coffee at 16 with
Sarita and then pop look with two-piece
what is he making [ __ ] it's like I don't
know what it does but it just moves me
man
oh my favorite thing I take out before I
even came here because I'm like I'm
going we're not on tour right now and so
I have like this chill time and it's
like I work out in the morning and then
I eat then I have time to chill and if I
don't have any work to do I'll take like
a bath for like an hour and a half and
write a little bit or just meditate or
whatever there's nothing better I get in
the bath water pop a fresh piece and
Nicorette in oh my god the worst part is
you stop finding these little wrappers
all right I got a memory where I cut
myself a few times I want to sue
Nicorette those are real ninja stars
right there those those [ __ ] Angela
these [ __ ] don't know guys if
you're confused in the morning you don't
know what [ __ ] the a DD pills don't even
work that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] listen to
me you get a 69 let's
the thing calls for [ __ ] one say you
gotta believe me you wanna make coffee
at the house if it calls for eight
ounces
you put windows in there yeah like I
don't give a [ __ ] what the judge says I
want my coffee to be blacker than black
I want to get up and go jack so you get
up you hit that [ __ ] coffee first and
let that balance out your body then you
go outside and hit that [ __ ] joint
you hit that zebra early and then you
finish the quality and then pop to
Nicorette it's over even if you don't
smoke cigarettes yeah oh yeah you know
what did it oh you're gay [ __ ] and will
you throw a [ __ ] star on this like
the THC star with two nickels what's a
star with that budget that two hundred
milligrams of pure THC boy can we like
do lashes with some nickel yeah
sometimes it might I'm tuned up on the
Stars I'll pop two wheels and Nicorette
zits all over spill it out and pop two
more to get the fresh nicotine juice you
don't see your face like that come on
good don't hold out do that is stocked
up I just went to the Costco oh I don't
know I got them on my travel bag for the
plane on a plane oh it's the best you
pop those on the plane with a little
vapor pen in the bathroom without
setting the alarm well forget you get
can you get away with hitting the vape
pen cuz I like cuz here's the deal is
cuz so we were traveling a lot and I had
the the e-cigarette vapor right and I go
and I had to actually take a [ __ ] too so
I go and I started taking a [ __ ] which
is like the first time I've ever done
that take a [ __ ] on an airplane and I'm
hitting the vape pen next thing I know
it's like it's like mister whoever is in
there you know the the fire alarms going
off as he keeps knocking and then and
I'm put the vape away and I'm starting
to freak out they opened the door
luckily you know I had my dick and my
balls out and I'm sitting on the toilet
of my pants now I'm taking a [ __ ] she
goes oh I'm so sorry she closes the door
but in my head I'm like [ __ ] I'm gonna
get out of here they're gonna [ __ ]
put me in handcuffs are they gonna you
know what I mean like I don't know how
this works they don't see the smoke they
can't do nothing tree really they just
eyeball you to death they want me to
mushy but so when I when I got out she
goes oh I'm so sorry she wants have a
faulty thing in there because yeah
they said there was a smoke alarm was
going off and I was like no idea and I
mean I've never been scared her because
that's like a you know just go to jail
for that [ __ ] yeah it's like a fine mm
they slap your wrist like I said not
again they knock it down at 200 in court
you do it you go in and do paperwork
that you [ __ ] suck dick for a living
dollars a week be the [ __ ] Cheerios
like a [ __ ] what you need to do
if you want to vape on my penance you
have to take the window out because
that's what the air conditioning oh for
sure yeah you have to hit it and cover
it with a sweater and make believe your
copernicus like you put your hands here
and blow down don't suck it right down
oh I've done that a million obese oh you
tough to smoke in the aisle seat
that's a tough year you got out the
window seat got a seat and you got it
listen the windows think you can hit
that vape or flop alright all four hours
by time you in your [ __ ] only want to
get off listen let's just go back I've
never especially if you ever seen been
on the plains where it looks like
there's miss coming out of it where it's
just like a super misty like right by
the window oh that's the best we were
flying to Bonnaroo and I was just I was
hit I wasn't even hiding it I was just
cuz I had nobody in that row and I was
just hitting the vape and it would just
like blow a cloud under the seat I don't
know you know it's the best man people
are [ __ ] but last time I did it one
of the times I was smoking on the plane
well a young girl kept saying mommy this
smoke and she kept saying that's not
smoke that's air-conditioning mommy
mommy I see smoke mommy mommy I see
smoke and she's like stop it Lindsay
that's nothing mom and the dad was like
what are you talking about you smoke
Danny watch and I would do it on purpose
right after they look away right after
they [ __ ] go look what and then she
finally got how worried she was I see
something but we don't understand you
hmm that's weird okay I'll ask the pilot
that was it nobody cares as long as you
don't blow in anybody's face nobody
gives a [ __ ] dude you know you mean
makes actually a plane smell better do
you work the Tempe improv I don't know
yet when you work 10 p.m. time they put
you in this Richie booty ho
and I've been staying there for years I
told the one time they put Rogan in my
room with me Rogan drew I get the
Rogen's room I got a pouch I go
downstairs to knock on his door and he's
got the little chintzy room on my book
[Laughter]
look at my room he's like pop they gave
you my room well we've been staying
there for a long time so his last time I
stayed there they have a smoking ban so
I would roll joints and go out with my
blue and they'd be having conferences
there's a restaurant underneath our
fresco restaurants I'd yeah a little
area where they have conferences it's
like a little setting deck and I would
[ __ ] lie to join it and smoke it like
a chimney and when they were looking
around I just have my blue out there but
I haven't my joint my right hand I
[ __ ] at them for all weekend jobs take
something they were everywhere maybe
then I would leave Lee joint for them in
the ashtray like a [ __ ] like
spider-man then the next day I would go
to they have a way that you could walk
out of the vestibule
through a thin alley but guess what if
it's windy you could smoke in that alley
and it goes right back for the thing
again I'm watching [ __ ] with radios I
smell it the last corner
I had them gonna [ __ ] bananas for for
[ __ ] I love torturing people at
marijuana smoke i lifes one of my most
favorite [ __ ] things there's
something I got to talk to you about
because you mentioned it but you didn't
[ __ ] mention it was that when I share
a certain passion that's the reason why
he's sitting on the chair it's not even
the passion I love you as a producer and
creator the goddamn comedy showing you
do a great job of Maggie but yeah
there's some there's a main reason why
you sitting there I love you as much as
I do couple usually you suffered a loss
and I live in LA a long time I've gone
through a couple of losses in LA
especially at the Comedy Store and they
always they always turn into
not only right there I always turn it
into ll a theatrical experience yeah you
know I had Marilyn who died in 2007
around the time I stopped doing blow and
I'm all these people I came to me and
cry that's the [ __ ] thing and I see
them on her birthday they never come up
to me there's only one personal calling
me on her birthday and every time I'm
driving to the County store I think
about it this could have been her
driving instead of me you know you just
think it's not something that I put on
myself with sad music sure I just no
wait then I say a little prayer for
Marilyn you know because she would have
been down there with me at The Comedy
Store can you find yourself far in life
in life I had early losses as a child
for these kids in grammar school and I
need not have one of my best friends
that was a [ __ ] savage but he loved I
did comedy I have their pictures up and
every Monday I put a glass of water
that's their prayer for them and I I
live for them in a way I go you know
what man and I know you were tight with
Angela mess with you and I know for a
fact that when I read the goddamn common
my god don't you stop me more because
I'm even crazier I'm sorry I brought
this no no no no it's not this the
podcast baby this woman no one I I love
P I love talking about Angelo Bowers
because I want other people that don't
know about him to look him up and look
up his comedy because he was great he
was one of the best or everybody
listening like look up Angelo Bowers
there's not a lot of clips of him but
the ones that are up there are great
where we shot the our special was
literally 200 feet away from where the
accident was like I so before the shoot
like so before the shooting life some
motherf alive some [ __ ] I just
a [ __ ] so I went I went to the
to the accident spot and I chilled out
and I put on some music and I kinda just
got present
talked to him a little bit went in did
the show not to take the subject off is
just a lot Alyssa doesn't know if you
get [ __ ] up you put two pieces of
nicotine gum in your mind chew it for
two minutes and drink a gallon of water
Oh washes that nicotine gum right into
your stomach you'll never feel the surge
like that in your life before yeah for
sure the [ __ ] work from up above it
then now you tell me this that it was
200 [ __ ] feet from the accident thing
you're like oh he's the reason the
reason I'm still doing stand-up the
reason I'm doing this show is because of
him he was the guy that told me to do it
you know what I mean it's so weird I try
to tell I'm 53 and I wouldn't be if I
didn't get science you get science man
you get science and you can't tell
people because right away they'll call
straitjacket for you I'm going you're
[ __ ] crazy or [ __ ] but you know
when you are Jesus Christ look what this
[ __ ] didn't laid out for me
he went but he never forgot me and he's
watching me watches me sometimes when I
make when I want to make a left
some of them might tell me to make it
right and you like [ __ ] what made me do
that one of these [ __ ] ghosts
that I got on my back cuz they don't
leave they don't leave they go into a
hole and that's [ __ ] so last and they
watch man but I gotta tell you I always
think Angelo for you for that cuz when I
saw that [ __ ] thing I know wow wipe
some [ __ ] I know you said the
same thing and now we're you proved it
to me so well he was a guy told me do
the show he told me he goes this is like
I mean I'm not long ago was but uh he's
still alive so I'm compiling 2010/2011
he's like dude he's like you you're
great doing stand-up but and I can tell
you having fun but there's there's
something about you doing music where
it's undeniable it's like you gotta
figure out a way to combine both those
whether it's mmm a show or it's a
disorder to that but just figure it out
and so when all that should happen in
2012 and then
you spend you know like I got you know I
got sober and then like started then I
got Montreal and [ __ ] did start going
right and I was like I don't know if I
want to do this anymore then I heard him
just do that show and I was like yeah
you're right you know what I mean I
should do that show because I'm not
gonna give up if I gave up he would have
been even more pissed and said I just
listened to what he said and it just
it's like when what we have like the
roadies on the show have you remember we
have the weave Jeremiah wakil arias
Johnny's cordis and Johnny when I asked
him to be the roadie I said to mother
but you want to be and he goes I don't
know what I'm supposed to do and I go
just do what Angela would think is funny
and just do what the [ __ ] you used to do
with him like his aunt used to like see
us and like puff his chest out and be
like super like aggressive but he was
like just kidding with us because the
nicest dude ever and I was like just do
that and that's what he does you know
what I mean it's literally he's got his
hand in every part of the show and he
it's a psyche it's just he's directing
and that's what he's making it's it's so
easy is because he's their man you know
he's a hundred percent they're good for
you man thank you I'm happy to all
worked out I'm happy that you got a sign
I'm happy that uh you know this all
worked on you're a great kid thank you
buddy you grow up around the air and
it's good to see these guys you know
with the traffic and with the coming
goal that we have when you see somebody
stick around and just stick to what he's
been doing
you know you Dean a bunch of guys I've
seen grow right and [ __ ] follow me so
it does something give some shoutouts
teddy Gregory Dustin and Oasis Bob
Lingus Sergio Ortega my man Matt Baker
up there and Bakersfield
Dustin Lukey our East in ham nobo in
Japan you bad [ __ ] and Ted
zoltan what are you nuts or what so
what's up with you Lee [ __ ] what'd
you think of the barbecue in Austin get
people to review well it was great what
have you had Bob I made barbecue wings
on Sunday with what there's the wings of
the hotel were great but okay so I
hadn't the first one we went to Austin
we were staying in this weird location
so I just took a cab one day and it was
like a chain people know it I talk to
people about in Austin it's a chain
that's in like gas station sort of but
it was fun it was good I enjoyed it and
then this time we had luckily Bobby
Sheeran and he took me to Black's and
there wasn't no because I would love in
theory to try franklin's but I can't I
was talking to some people like if
they're like 6:00 in the morning that's
too much that that's I can't do that
so blacks there wasn't like there was
like a line for like five minutes we got
Bobby Karen tricked me then he told me
to get a beef rib which I didn't know
was like the fun stones salads tolerate
the whole thing no I couldn't hey most I
got a half a pound of brisket that I got
a potato salad I'm starving right oh
he's just talking about Bobby what do
you think of Texas as a whole it has a
really bad reputation where I'm from
it's really weird because I don't know
it's uh where I'm from is mostly
Democrat I don't get us and there's
mostly Republican and it's just it's
crazy how much it divides people so I
always hear about Texas like I forget
who we were talking about but if someone
was driving across country and they said
don't stop on these towns like that's
what people will say to me about Texas
like don't you know won't be a Jew in
Texas and then when I moved down here I
started hearing about Austin what's up
buddy you know might what it might have
been how we how this dates me but I was
a kid and what the real world was there
the show was and they they had like a
video thing and that that was their job
they were working itself by Southwest
and I that was right when I wanted to
start doing video so they got that
Austin might be [ __ ] cool that might
be nice and then you hear about it you
hear about it and the every time I go my
mind mine it changed my life driving
cross-country here the first time that I
drove through the south and they're just
[ __ ] nicer I just there even at the
gas station is just sweet like you said
you said you hate Waffle House I'll
always love Waffle House because every
time we go in the nice well the food
glad I know the food's terrible foot of
the service this guy smile how can you
can't mess up a waffle I mean just don't
get eggs my hope goes in there for
[ __ ] walk
well that doesn't mean you go in there
for [ __ ] one thing if you do I've sat
in there with ten times I never had a
walk actually we got the eggs there we
actually just went I went to Waffle
House for the first time when I was in
Tennessee doing Bonnaroo and everybody
got to get the you gotta get the
hashbrowns what they called I don't know
they're like it's like cheese and
something else on there cause like split
it and win it save like a David
something something real quasi racism
aid somebody made up and it was [ __ ]
he was literally like it was like it was
literally just like like hash browns you
get a Denny's with a piece of cheddar
cheese on it oh yeah I don't get
anything but waffles there but the whole
point was there and then the past few
times both times everyone I mean
whenever I would get to go and and say
hi or everyone's just so nice to me
there and it's uh first of all I've
never looked at it as a Republican or
Democrat I've never considered myself
anything as a child nothing I always
thought that was the dumbest [ __ ]
thing I ever heard in my life so I've
never thought about it that way but let
me reality about taxes for me in my life
I cut my comedy piece of taxes you were
saying if I break my dates down that I
worked in the taxes it would have
probably been five years six years out
of my twenty five years and they went
along for the rides
you know I bombed in a lot of places
Austin was one of the pipes to bomb an
Austin all the time because they're
conservative in a way a little bit more
like it's kind of like it salty it's
alright there's no chain it's a little
bit more a bit more they you know people
say it's more free thinking I've had
great times in [ __ ] Houston in Dallas
I've had great times I've had great
times in El Paso I've been one of the
nights of commie laughter harnessed in
my life was an Amarillo comedy club it's
closed now it's not even thought to be a
comedy club one of the hardest nights I
ever left him and there was six people
in the audience who wasn't it was myself
and Mike Feynman was the feature act and
I tell you this two guys this girl had
the waitress there
the biggest breasts you ever seen in
your life and they were real oh she was
a chubby Mexican girl but her tits had
just something happened to her and she
was about to go for the surgery to get
him reduced to get him reduced by half
because they would just ginormous
ginormous and she wasn't a stripper she
was a student that kind of stopped going
to school because they ridiculed Jesus a
mother was Mexican the dad was Mexican
they owned the Mexican restaurant next
door to it and there was a comedy called
dish froggy bottoms had been there for
years
uh-huh see if froggy bottoms too openly
and what want to have a reuleaux Texas
well I think it's Amarillo but let's
just ask froggy bottom comedy club and
that club they closed and they felt so
bad they hope there's a restaurant but
then people started coming in going
where's the comedy where's the comedy
and they started calling they didn't
know what they were doing yeah no idea
they do nothing they have one in a
little bit Lubbock is it still open I
think so let's see Lubbock it wasn't
that Murillo Amarillo was Kelly Moran's
no it closed according to Yelp how long
ago let me check that uh-huh
because it was like roses Mexican
restaurant Lisa act your head would have
blown up at this place I never forgot
how good the tamale was with lettuce and
cheese on top of the lettuce they get
from restaurant next door the restaurant
on the comedy club they had little
buying it and they have a daughter named
Julia mm-hmm
nothing about promotions nothing we get
there they had a condo that they bought
from the comedy club nice condo and nice
little [ __ ] three days but that
particular man I was on stage for six
people and there was one guy that was
drinking doubles and every time he'd
look at her you could see that his her
tits were getting bigger right he was
just gonna look at me like it and at
first it was like he was very polite he
was a Christian there you could see that
he raised well but after six drinks
those titties of those titties mobbed a
cup of nicotine gums and he was off to
the race he was off and running
and he would just sit there and go oh
yeah like every time it was like using
his living room calling his wife yeah I
mean look like he'd go look at the size
of your titties oh yeah and then she
would walk away they go oh yeah so by
the end of the show he was [ __ ]
hammered hammered by the end of the show
and all he would say is Julio and he
would those off for two minutes and
people who goofing on him and throwing
[ __ ] out of me wake up me go Julio yeah
what is it
he went home saying holy and every time
he said earlier I gotta tell you I'm
just funny than anything I had to say
cuz I was on the stage just laughing it
don't alcohol put him into that man on
fire house mostest we had is getting
drunk in and pass out yet and you're
mumbling things to yourself he was
mumbling things about his childhood I
mean there was a mental health issue
do you drink drinker I don't think I was
gonna say I don't think I've ever seen
you drink I'm so paranoid I'm drinking
and driving up that [ __ ] hill
somebody hits me in the copses have you
been drinking and I gotta tell him yes
but I got a [ __ ] pee in a bottle I
got a needle with my [ __ ] Imam will
give it breathalyzer mm-hmm I'd rather
not do anything at all sure you know I
uh in 1980 I did acid I went there was
little on the way home I saw this
accident car was on fire there was a
girl [ __ ] cut in half an rx-7 they
were trying to take her and the
boyfriend out how call everywhere and
that night I made a mental note I'm
never drinking [ __ ] driving 1980
mmm-hmm and I just I can have a machine
gun and a dead body in my trunk and it
will not bother me as much as if I have
ones right yeah and drive yeah if I see
one calm I fall apart I do not fall
apart or anything
if I'm drinking it's like being in a
stolen car I never stole the car in my
life it's the dumbest thing in the world
they caught you it you're ready that's
it I can't lose it you don't and yes
that way we don't know
I'm not you know credit card search the
house yeah we didn't find the credit
card okay this litigation will happen to
the card I got a more [ __ ] up on the
[ __ ] investigation will the police go
when the cop was stolen car minute it's
the same thing with drinkin and I always
thought I'm with it I would not know
talkin get behind a wheel of a [ __ ]
car you got really mad at me when you
heard that I drink and drive you wanted
like I waited until I'd like the yen no
no not even accepted in my world cuz
it's old news
that's all [ __ ] by this point everybody
should know that's oh [ __ ] you is yeah
especially with the day and age of uber
yeah no no no no it's all [ __ ] loose
yeah to me in my world it was known all
those 15 years ago like 15 years ago
they caught you drinking and driving you
should have got smacked knocked the [ __ ]
out in 10 days automatically in jail
that's how I really feel like ten days
well I have something tomorrow too bad
it's like when they catch with a gun in
Manhattan you get to you know you get
caught with a handgun on no license in
Manhattan or something have that the law
and you go right to the tombs you get
processed the next morning really going
home there's no saying goodbye to your
family there's no telling your work that
you [ __ ] up
that's the consequences you know what
until you do consequences like that like
I was in prison with two guys definitely
nicest kids in the world that went out
for three drinks after the problem all
went out one night after Chi Beta Kappa
they had four beers and they ran into a
friend they don't [ __ ] around in some
states both of them killed somebody or
put some way in the hospital you know
right there that's it right that's it
not only number two I'm a comic what
other car yeah that's a lonely career
dog I saw it I saw it two or three times
comics I got duis and then when I was
first starting they gonna call you and
you gotta meet them and then they live
in the edge of hell
no nothing to do I'll Drive my old
[ __ ] car I don't want to know creepy
[ __ ] and smoking cigarettes
listen to shangri-la music I gotta put
up with that [ __ ] for a [ __ ] hour
[ __ ] you and the horse you rode up on
man
no no no no so no there's so many
disadvantages to a bus for me you want
to scare Joey Diaz tummy's gonna take a
bus um I'll take a train in New York the
comprehensive coke last night man
no and the bus yeah
never will I drink and drive well in New
York it's like getting in the subways
just like it's nothing it's just it's a
beautiful thing it's like part of the
city and like you know and you have the
option to take a cab because it more
accessible but in LA it's like if you
have a car you're fine wait in my car
tonight
I don't smoke at night I just don't you
can get caught here with weed they won't
do anything right but I'll smoke when I
come over to help but why yeah you have
to show them your license then they talk
to you and they give you a ticket then
you got to go to court with that [ __ ]
license and then plead out think I
started making over the court you're
still gonna get a ticket for it maybe
I'm a joint though you just I don't know
I don't know but I've heard why take the
chance
sure cuz that Thursday I have to leave
town for [ __ ] one of my biggest weeks
you know I'm sailing one of my favorite
weeks and I gotta call that comedy club
and tell them why because this is
resonates I get it that type of [ __ ]
resume so you don't want at night I
don't want to smoke I smoke when I come
over the hills I get over hit my spark I
pulled over he was smoking the Comedy
Store since I've been back to one night
with the kids I took to it I had a joint
like David um and I felt weird that I
was giving him a joint I can walk on it
mm-hmm I didn't want them to say Joey
what the [ __ ] would you put in there you
know same so I took two eggs just the
left it was a waitress I didn't want to
think that I gotta yeah yeah
so I never but besides that I don't
really try to I never shitty weed they
give him one of those free joints from
[ __ ] from their things yeah one of
the dispensaries yeah apparently they're
working on a way to figure out if your
uh honey yeah that's why no white break
that you talk to him long enough and
you'll find out you know you gotta do is
ask him a couple questions like I mean
alcohol is so easy is this on your
breath weed is like you just you could
tell man you can tell before I have
my [ __ ] salaries from marijuana in
edibles the NRA the thousand milligrams
I was driving home and I'm like I'm not
high no like I wouldn't get in the car
if I even have like that suspicion isn't
tons of night me and Lea's fist city of
two hours after we're just talking and
the reality is just cuz I don't want to
get in the [ __ ] car
cuz you so high or you just don't yeah I
just know that this this there's a time
when I could get in the car and there's
a time when I can't get in the [ __ ]
car
yeah I know I know he when you smoke a
couple joints it's uh you'll had a
garbage can or sticking out I've been
down that road already guys I wouldn't
[ __ ] function as I knew about you
know I don't crash cars I had garbage
cans and those cones God always puts
those cones in my way rearview mirrors
I've knocked off Henry all right yeah
and I'm not some two of my own and ten
of somebody else's you know so you just
know you know when you get the car
driving stuff as is sober like it's just
so many [ __ ] [ __ ] on the road
that I got I got cut off on the way here
tonight in the way guys that you gotta
pull over and say call him a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I hope your mother's head blows
up when she's sucking your father's dick
or something evil to him you're the pop
to nicotine gums is to calm yourself
down I don't have time for it I didn't
have time to be penny Moore if you're
that [ __ ] [ __ ] you're gonna get
yours you're gonna get used cuz I could
have been drunk and doing ninety and you
want to play that let me just do it
right so you could slow down and [ __ ]
with you a little bit really there you
go now you go right there
they just caught another one let me get
the paper what's up wink did you ever
have like um
I got when I first are doing polish you
would like it upset because of how upset
I get behind the wheel and you know like
it's weird how it like you get so upset
but it doesn't really stay with you at
least for me it doesn't like I'll be
furious long driving I've thrown paint
scans of people know I used to keep in
my G base to keep like bolts and I used
to throw those at cars that would do
[ __ ] up [ __ ] one letter I'm the [ __ ]
one of those the five for ten miles I
fought one of guys throwing pennies Adam
I cracked his [ __ ] windshield he
chased me I pulled off I threw more
pennies Adam I got his windshield and I
went home I know what the [ __ ] that I
just do what the [ __ ] how old am I what
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
this guy could had a [ __ ] missile
launcher he could have been Isis on his
way to a [ __ ] house party and Here I
am throwing pennies at some [ __ ] guy
from my middle Council cuz he at me oh
you know what these type of guys they
like cut somebody off when somebody's
texting and he's doing 90s I take the
rear end this guy's gonna be in a
[ __ ] wheelchair the rest of his life
and he'll figure it out don't figure it
the [ __ ] out yeah I used to get mad man
I had a buddy that would just scream
bloody murder man peeing like it was his
dad I think he thought it that's his dad
that is who thought it was cool if he
did it and I mean he would [ __ ] just
can't [ __ ] yeah fine I think dude you
look ridiculous right now the guy he has
no idea like just give him the finger
move on I mean you can get up close to
him dude I had a woman do something so
stupid recently on Sunset we're like I
could have died another car could died
and so I pulled up next to her and I
have a window down anything this super
most calm way I was like do you realize
what you could have done you almost
killed me in another car and she just
stared red okay
they lose their head she started she
rolled her window I wish you saw me
coming up and I should hear me they do
not care they don't give a [ __ ] okay
he looks ittle bit evens at prom
sometimes that they when people have
that attitude they're not gonna change
and soon enough someday they'll get this
no for sure you know it I you that
didn't now at this point I'm like it's
not even worth it
I've got so many god bless you I've got
so many tickets when I first got my
Cadillac man like I I didn't realize how
fast it was and I I got a shitload of
ticket oh yes I got out you know cts cts
B and I didn't realize how a couple
students [ __ ] v8 is powerful as [ __ ]
and also I was on opiates because when I
got it I was like that was when I still
use it so I was [ __ ] dude one time I
got from the Hollywood improv to the
Irvine improv in like 35 minutes like I
was going 120 the whole way at 11
at night so I can make my spot with
dustin ybarra and nick yeah
just [ __ ] just balling I got so many
tickets and literally like my insurance
went up all this other [ __ ] to the point
now where I take my time my daddy's
always say that he's a dude just take
your time you're gonna get there
just you know be a defensive driver I
took all the guy to take classes I do
all this [ __ ] to keep my license and and
now I mean I literally Drive offensive
drugs take my time
whoo you know what I mean yeah you know
what I mean there's going like this is
like going 7080 miles an hour
but there's also going 7080 miles an
hour in a straight line not going gin
gin just curving through different cars
that's when you're gonna like I know
you're the best doesn't you end up dead
you know did I used to [ __ ] just you
know smoke well that was always like
smoking weed and driving like drinking
it actually drinking and driving I was
like really good at I have three duis
but I thought people are good at that
[ __ ] girl go check it out they just sent
me pictures from Black Sabbath you
should've gone dude I feel like such an
ass we could have done this tomorrow
night no not at all my friend and we
couldn't have done it tomorrow night
check it out we say
I all know how to [ __ ] do it
he's right there
- oh I just saw speaking of Rage Against
the Machine you just want the scene I
just saw prophets of rain how were they
ah okay here's the deal
Rage Against the Machine is not it's
like this the tom morello the fan is
incredible but Zack de la Rocha is that
[ __ ] he's what makes that band he's what
he's like the icing on a delicious cake
already
it's so perfect with him as a lead
singer to have Chuck D and and be real
it just wasn't good enough in my opinion
it's like this like if if Queen wants
the tour right like they have to get a
new singer because Freddie Mercury died
Zack de la Rocha is living in Tustin
like he's there he can do the goddamn
show if he wants to it's like that's
what hurt me even more said why can't he
just do it we need Rage Against the
Machine right now with all the [ __ ] up
political [ __ ] going on in the world
like you need that voice you need this
band more right now than ever before
they came out like this is it with
[ __ ] Trump running for president like
we need that banner given the finger the
[ __ ] man and it just it was it was
like I've seen Rage Against the Machine
live who is probably the best live band
I've ever seen so it just didn't live up
to it everybody else was going babe [ __ ]
bananas they were going [ __ ] bananas
and I was just like you [ __ ]
have no idea you don't know these are
for people it's like there was literally
like a Rage Against the Machine cover
band it was an amateur and they all
[ __ ] took the bait they took the bait
that's all and it's you know what when
you're watching them unless you're
[ __ ] an amateur you could you're like
this is just something that'll be for a
while you know I came I enjoyed it you
know what I did
[ __ ] drank to Red Bulls Bop probably
like 15 pieces of nicotine gum
that's [ __ ] rode that way baby gotta
bother you a little nicotine gum with
the sugarless [ __ ] Red Bull it's what
I did I did that before I came here dude
on the right what do you think you're
dealing with amateurs do the sugar
redbull it's without this sugar that
pushing with a different [ __ ]
planet you understand me I love you know
you got you have no idea how much that
moment when you saw that nicotine gum
when look let me get a piece [ __ ] that
made me that was the greatest part of my
I'm gonna pack myself again
I got okay I'll give you a ten back in
my car baby I know that you have to do
it that's I couldn't get you the juju
beads that you want it's awesome
nicotine gum I don't read a lot of
magazines I really don't have from time
to time now I read people I like that
the first couple pages of people Rolling
Stone the first couple pages of Rolling
Stone or if I see like that a specific
article goal about the Rolling Stone
they did a bunch of articles about Pink
Floyd last year's make them up Jerry
Rocha picks them up whatever that's my
experience here with it but this texture
that I'm going to tell you guys about
I've heard nothing but great things from
people who fly especially people who fly
and have three or four magazines people
some people read magazines away some
people [ __ ] listen to podcast so
thanks to pizza were all binge eating
thanks to Netflix more binge watching
but now with texture you could start to
binge read like when people are [ __ ]
doing trust me
it's about to be a thing when it comes
to magazines you know what you like and
with texture you can get all the
magazines you want in one super
convenient place text has completely
reimagine reimaged magazines giving you
the articles and stories you really want
all in one place plus interactive
features videos and recommendations just
for you okay the texture app lets you
tap into the world's most popular
magazines anytime anyplace using your
smartphone or tablet
breeze through hundreds of favorite
magazines including back issues
magazines like Motor Trend Men's Journal
Men's Health Men's Fitness entrepreneur
ESPN magazine Forbes fortune Sports
Illustrated teen vogue The New Yorker
this old house Vanity Fair today's
parent
Town and Country and the list goes on
and on texture has made it easy to find
articles you care about I don't just get
to read this magazine
I mentioned but you can also get the
other ones I mentioned from ski to
Smithsonian to Southern Living to Sports
Illustrated kids to successful farming I
mean it goes on and on and on what I'm
gonna do is this sign up the texture
right now and gain inside access access
to all the content from the world's best
publications the best part is textures
off from my listeners of free trial
right now when you go to texture comm
slash Joey you'll gain immediate entry
for all the top magazines including back
issues and bonus video content start
binge reading for free right now when
you go to texture Tom slash Joey again
that's texture calm slash Joey the
texture app isn't it entirely digital so
it's super environmentally friendly way
to consume the best magazines and
articles again right now free go to
texture calm slash Joey Lee so far how
many pounds of you I know you [ __ ]
blew up a little bit Austin but I've
been really blueprint has really been
helping me I I wasn't cooking before
blue apron host it was too much to go
get recipes I was cooking the same two
things with blue apron it comes it
literally comes to my house with
everything that I need so I'm an I'm a
jerk I'm a jerk if I don't do it now
what days does it come it's coming
tomorrow comes Tuesday let's see I I'm
looking forward I haven't even looked to
see what I'm getting it's like I like it
because I always I like you can go like
a month in advance and like pick your
meals but I because I just forget and
it's like a surprise when it comes in
let's see what I'm getting that's give
me two seconds I knew like all the stuff
that comes in a box you eat the
vegetables you use all the products
buddy yeah yeah I mean I'm not gonna
saying everything has been my favorite
meal but like it's been interesting
because I've never once I did that juice
thing for a while and I had kale and he
made fun of it and a couple of things
have had Kalinin time wasn't and that's
not gonna be good it was like a kale
corn like stir-fry thing pretty good
that's well anyway as long as like the
ingredients let me talk to you about
blue apron
not all ingredients
created equal fresh high-quality
ingredients taste better and a better
for you so it's important to know where
your food comes from talk about you know
for less than $10 per meal blue apron
will deliver seasonal recipes along with
pre-portion ingredients to make you a
delicious home-cooked meal proportion
that's the package right there blue
apron knows that when you cook with
incredible ingredients you make
incredible meals so they set the highest
quality standards for their community
suppliers family-run farms fisheries and
ranches whether it's a Japanese ramen
noodles or the wild corn alaskan salmon
or the heirloom tomatoes blue apron is
bringing you the best okay what we're
gonna do is this it's nice and simple
they mail your box right Lee yeah they
mailboxes everything so this week listen
to this I'm getting Korean pork tacos
with spicy red cabbage slaw I'm also
getting blackened chicken with zucchini
rice corn and cherry tomatoes and then
I'm getting brown butter and thyme
gnocchi with matt with mushrooms and
Swiss chard look at the other group look
at this crispy salmon and orzo salad and
that might be the family crispy pork
chops with lemon mussels oh-lee oh-lee
chicken fried rice I mean this is just
tremendous summer squash with mozzarella
and Takashi Oh pizza new recipes are
created weekly and are not repeated
within the year choose your meals from a
variety of recipes or let blue aprons
killing every team surprise you listen
you make up your mind you're killing
yourself for less than $10 a meal blue
apron I'll give you a dinner of your
life let's do this I'm gonna do this for
you tonight you're gonna get your first
three meals for free that's free
free2play pranaam slash Joey that's blue
apron calm slash Joey thank you guys for
listening to the show
don't forget most important there's a
few [ __ ] tickets left for New York
City don't hit me up on Twitter st. Joey
there's no tickets left last week an
Austin same [ __ ] thing happen Friday
all day on Twitter Joey I know tickets
guess there's nothing there's nothing I
get for people I'm going to New York so
don't come crying to me if you want
tickets I know Saturday night sold out
already in New York oh [ __ ] there's
three [ __ ] days to rock the house get
on those [ __ ] and I'll have
another date to the LAT no there's only
three more no expectation till it shows
and that's October 29th at the [ __ ]
ice house so you got New York and the
ice house the week after that what do
you got coming up dozen October 4th
we're gonna be at the Roxy the goddamn
Comedy Jam at the Roxy every Thursday
night you can see me at the Hollywood
improv at midnight snacks and masses
Thursday night Center this Saturday
check my Instagram all that [ __ ] to
find out also we'll be at the New York
Comedy Festival November [ __ ] everybody
look at this because you're talking
about it hold on well we're gonna be a
Houston don't worry he was weird Houston
in November what they tell them the day
member 18th I just don't know what
exactly is the time I think it's a whole
weekend that's the whole thing so I know
I'm there Friday night one night so
we're doing November 5th we're at
Gramercy Theater if you're in New York
to see the goddamn Comedy Jam guys you
could check me out on all social media
is Josh Adam Meyers the goddamn Comedy
Jam is the GD Comedy Jam man and watch
it on Comedy Central and say a prayer
hopefully we go to series and then Joey
Diaz can can do a much better quality
taping of of killing in the name of
[ __ ] dude will do freedom by Rage
Against the Machine just wanna have fun
[ __ ] whipping post will do everything
Lisa at we might be back tomorrow we
might not we might just see you next
week but don't forget we love you
[ __ ] stay black have a great day
Thank You Josh I think I have to find
you I love you both stay black
[ __ ] do you know won't close Rage
Against the Machine killing in the name
thank you brother
you
you